this is a production of cornell
university
thanks to need for that introduction um
and yeah you gave away my secret i'm
actually in georgia right now
you probably can't tell by the cast iron
uh
wood stove behind me but i am in georgia
um
and yeah thank you all for coming today
i'd like to
present my dissertation work for my phd
uh i've i've really focused uh my work
on laboratory experiments looking at the
role of microbial metabolism
in the formation of mineral associated
organic matter and i've put this picture
here on the title slide to try to get us
in the right frame of mind
this is uh looking down on a b horizon
that i've uncovered
at arnon forest and hopefully you can
see there's a fungal hyphy stretching
across this
the surface of this b horizon um so this
mineral rich b
horizon and my talk today is really
going to focus at that interface
uh looking at uh organic matter
decomposition
and the role of microbial metabolism in
bridging that interface between plant
litter
and uh stable organic matter
so in the martinez lab we work at the
molecular scale
and as mechanistic questions and so i
wanted to start off by just talking
about soil organic matter from a
molecular perspective
and the way i think about it so i've
adapted this figure
but i typically think about plant litter
input to the soil
i could come from various sources
detritus or root inputs
and the big distinction here is smaller
compounds
uh such as low molecular weight monomers
dna rna lipids and proteins
and the much much larger uh polymers
that make up some uh plant materials
such as cellulose hemicellulose and
lignin
these inputs into the soil are then
broken down
by both biotic and abiotic mechanisms so
you might have depolymerization by
exoenzymes or degradation from uv light
or shrink swell processes
that can then take these larger
compounds and break them into their
substituent components then
you could have microbial biomass that
transforms these compounds into
non-living soil organic matter
so the main thing i want to point out is
that there are two pathways microbially
derived
and plant derived so an abiotic and a
biotic pathway
for the formation of non-living soil
organic matter and then i really want to
focus in on one
portion of soil organic matter which is
mineral associated organic matter
and that's of importance to me because
this fraction we know to be
more stable in in many situations uh to
have longer turnover times and longer
radiocarbon
dates uh and also to have higher
signatures of microbial transformation
so it's more microbial derived
and so i entered this field of research
as a master's student at the university
of georgia
and i was fortunate enough to do some
work looking at the impact of
plant litter chemistry on decomposition
in the formation of mineral associated
organic matter and what we found
is higher quality litters which we
denoted as
lower uh acid unhydrolyzable residues or
lower hemicellulose and lignin content
to higher protein content resulted in um
more microbial biomass and more mineral
associated organic matter so we could
track the formation of mineral
associated organic matter
and collect observations that indicated
that this was done because of increased
carbon use efficiency
so not only was this potentially stable
pool of organic matter being increased
by this higher quality plant letter but
less co2 was being
being emitted in the process and so that
really got me interested in this
concept of carbon use efficiency in the
microbial community as drivers
of soil organic matter stabilization
for my phd i really wanted to zoom in
to the molecular scale and from the
microbial perspective
and so i really wanted to focus on just
low molecular weight monomers
and how they are transformed by
different microbes
in the soil environment and how that may
drive the process
of mineral associated organic matter
formation so the questions i came in
with
are what is the role of substrate
identity there are all of these
compounds in soil solution what's the
role of their identity on metabolism
can we develop a framework that's
applicable broadly
across different uh lifestyles to
predict monomer uptake rates
and the efficiency of use of those
monomers
how does phylogeny so you know whether
it's a fungus or a bacterial isolate
or the growth rat growth rate impact
metabolism of these compounds
and then lastly how do these metabolic
processes uh impact the formation of
mineral
associated organic matter and so this
was really interesting to me
for many reasons um it's a very small
scale mechanistic questions
they're very basic foundational and
they're also increasingly being
incorporated into models
these types of observations so i was
hopeful that i could collect some
empirical
data sets to help modelers move forward
so before we go further we should define
clearly what carbon use efficiency is
and how i think about it
so this is my cartoon of a bacterial
cell
it's in soil solution it's surrounded by
all of these compounds
potential substrates to create biomass
from
not all of them are readily available
they can't all be assimilated across the
cellular envelope
so exo enzymes may be needed to break
down these compounds into their monomer
subunits these compounds can then be
uptaken or assimilated
either one at a time or sequentially or
in groups
and that can facilitate growth or
maintenance respiration
releasing co2 as these organisms either
survive or grow
in the soil environment and so we can
calculate carbon use efficiency if we
know how much carbon
has been put into the biomass versus the
total amount assimilated so the amount
in the
biomass and the amount respired and so
that gives an efficiency a proportion of
that carbon
that was maintained in in the cell
so once you start thinking about these
things at the at the cellular level uh
there are other interesting
questions that that pop up such as um
how do we determine substrate
preferences
uh which compounds are assimilated uh in
what order
and then are compounds used together is
there co-utilization of substrates or do
we see more classical dioxic patterns
where
one substrate is used after the other in
a sequential fashion
and that's more of the classical
paradigm of substrate preference
utilization in microbiology
i want to define one other term which is
a finer point on
carbon use efficiency which is i'm
calling substrate use efficiency
and that's in this mixed substrate
environment we could track the carbon
from one compound
with isotopes perhaps and so the sugar
for example
even though multiple compounds are being
assimilated we can track the carbon from
just that substrate
into the biomass and into respiration
and calculate a compound specific
use efficiency rate which here i'm
calling
sue
so for my dissertation work
there were three main objectives of this
work and i'm going to share some of the
work
or some of the data from those projects
the first two objectives are focused uh
on microbial metabolism
and we wanted to evaluate substrate
energy content
or the oxidation state of substrates as
a potential predictor for microbial
substrate preference
and substrate use efficiency the second
objective is we wanted to test the
impact of physiology
on carbon use efficiency and the any
relationship we observe between
uh energy content and substrate use
efficiency
and then the third objective is separate
and is really focused on the formation
of mineral associated organic matter
and we wanted for this talk we wanted to
assess the functional groups
involved in formation of maom
from microbial necromass
so to carry this out in a practical
sense
i'm employed a model systems approach
we chose a field site at arnet forest
a site that's also been researched by
many others
including the goodale lab we chose a
hemlock hardwood
stand um oh so i forgot to say this is
uh right near newfield outside of ithaca
and we chose a hemlock hardwood stand to
study uh this is a young inseptosol
well-drained and we sampled the oa and b
horizons to get material for future uh
for further experimentation
i then needed to create a soil solution
analog
to culture microbes in so i made a
a water extract a t if you will of this
oa horizon and so it's got this orangish
tint it's
pretty acidic but the idea here is that
it's
it's an analog for a rainfall event
where you have aerated water percolating
downward
and being utilized by the microbial
community
then we needed to characterize this this
tea we made
so we hit it with a suite of analytical
approaches to try to understand
what carbon substrates were there and in
what concentrations
they were available to the community
we then created an isolate library where
we chose
20 isolates both fungal and bacterial
isolated from this site
we also isolated them on the soil
extract
so the selection pressure was that we
chose organisms that would likely
respond
uh to a rainfall event
to the percolation of this carbon-rich
solution downward we then use 16s and
its
amplicon sequencing to better identify
them
and we characterize their growth rates
so the first chapter i'm going to talk
about i
i took one of these organisms and grew
it in the soil extract
and we quantified substrate uptake
growth
carbon use efficiency during growth
in that soil extract
we then used the data from that
experiment to create a defined media
for practical reasons extracting enough
of this
soil t every time it just wasn't
it wasn't feasible so we created a
realistic defined
media with many carbon substrates at low
concentration
and then we used that to conduct an
experiment looking at substrate
preferences such as use efficiency and
carbon use efficiency across a growth
rate gradient
using isolates from our library and then
lastly we brought in a mineral component
isolating clays from the site from the b
horizon
and also synthesizing a model iron oxide
gertite
for use in further absorption
experiments and so that's the third
chapter of my dissertation looking at
source effects on the retention of
microbial necromancers
so before i go further i wanted to just
give the hypothesis for the first two
experiments
so again we're tracking the fate of low
molecular weight organic substrates in
solution and the first hypothesis that
we wanted to investigate or the first
hypothesis i had that we hope to to
collect observations for against was
that higher
uh compounds with higher nominal
oxidation state of carbon
more oxidized compounds would be used
less efficiently
by various isolates and this was
resulting from
literature in the physiology
in the field of microbial physiology and
soil science
so this this plot shows substrate use
efficiency
and then nominal oxidation state of
carbon on the x-axis
going from most reduced such as methane
to most oxidized like co2
and research from the physiology
literature gammers at all
reviews it nicely showed that for
individual carbon substrates used alone
there's a clear trend where more
oxidized compounds are used less
efficiently
and there's a good thermodynamic
underpinning to
why this is the case but the interesting
thing is when we spike soils with these
different compounds we see similar
trends
so that's the other colors overlaying
here
but it's less clear if that's because of
the universal
framework within the metabolism of all
microbes or because of
which microbes are using these compounds
in a mixed community
and then the second hypothesis that we
wanted to look at was how
growth rate of different isolates
impacts overall carbon use efficiency
and any relationship with the use of
specific substrates
and so this is an observation that has
already been incorporated into
global models actually that
faster growing organisms tend to have
lower carbon use efficiencies
and faster growing slower growing
organisms excuse me have
higher carbon use efficiencies and
that's based on quite a bit of culture
work but there's less work been done
at concentrations that are realistic for
soil solution so we wanted to collect
data to confirm
or disprove that
so to begin with uh the first thing we
did was characterize this soil solution
um i took some basic measurements of ph
and electrical conductivity that's a
very acidic solution
which isn't surprising because we're
under hemlock uh
forest cover i did find more carbon than
i expected roughly 183 milligrams of
carbon per liter
we can see that there's some ammonium i
found known nitrate
and that most of the nitrogen was in the
form of amino acids
or other organic nitrogen
and that with color metric methods i
could see quite a bit of the carbon was
in the form of reducing sugars so that's
very
you know crude bulk observations of the
solution
we then could use uh fancier
exometabolomic methods proton nmr
and liquid chromatography to quantify
specific low molecular weight substrates
so here we have concentration on the
y-axis
and then roughly i believe 30 compounds
that we quantified
on the x and you can see that we saw a
large gradient
in concentration ranging from 0.4 to 236
micromolar so the main takeaway here is
that
there are many substrates um and they
are at very
diverse concentrations in this soil
solution
so what we could quantify only explain
twenty percent of carbon
and 40 of nitrogen
but that's a pretty sizable fraction for
such a small number of compounds
we identified another 150 compounds
that we couldn't quantify but we know
are in solution
so now i want to uh show some results
from the first chapter
uh this was an eco-physiological study
of
one of the isolates para berkold area
solid sugar
on soil extract and this was a nice side
collaboration during
my phd with rowley wilhelm and the
buckley lab
and several other members in the buckley
lab and we were able to take one of
these isolates further characterize it
and actually name it
so this is data on that organism growing
in soil extract it's a gram-negative
parabola species
so we grew the isolate to log phase
overnight and then we use that to
inoculate
culture flask with 12 replicates then
with time we could
sample those flasks and measure carbon
nitrogen
biomass and protein and then filter
to conduct our exo metabolomic
measurements to see what was changing in
extracellular solution
so here is the growth curve
to orient you on the y-axis we have
optical density at 600 nanometers
which also correlates to biomass uh
over here on this axis and protein
content
and then on the x-axis we have time in
hours
i fit the growth curve with a black line
here
but the actual sampling points are in
red so we sampled four points along the
curve
trying to capture log phase and i've
included the starter flask here just to
try to prove to you that my modeled fit
for stationary phase is realistic
i want to go back real quick and just
note that we missed quite a bit early on
even though we did capture a portion of
the curve but you'll see that come into
play
later when we look at specific
substrates
so i don't want to spend too much time
on this but i just want to show that we
have bulk measurements of carbon and
nitrogen dynamics in solution that we
could take these
and with time we could we could follow
movement of carbon outside of
extracellular solution into the cell
and into respired co2 for instance
and we could track kind of bulk species
such as reducing sugars right
same with nitrogen we can track ammonium
uptake here in the orange color or amino
acids in the pink
and from that we were able to see that
just over a quarter of carbon available
in solution was
assimilated by this microbe about 18
of that initial carbon was lost as co2
we could explain
a large fraction roughly 30 percent with
reducing sugars
and an even larger fraction with amino
acids
with this data we could also calculate
carbon use efficiency
and so here i've got cue on the y-axis
and time
on the x-axis going up to 24 hours
and what i want to show here is that
this fit is for cumulative
cue and we can see that that
increases with growth plateauing at
about 0.4
or 40 of carbon assimilated was was
maintained in in biomass
and if we look at instantaneous carbon
use efficiency we can see that that's
much higher
at these uh during this growth phase
so you know cue is very low early on
it rapidly increases right and then
slows down again as growth slows down
so this value of 0.4 is right in the
middle of what you'd expect in the
literature
and it also happens to be the ballpark
number used in many models
and it also fits some emerging
relationships between growth rate
and carbon use efficiency so the point
there is that our measurements were
seem to be working and producing
realistic values
okay moving from here i want to show
some of the exome metabolomic data
this is just one example for citrate so
citrate was in this
citra was in the soil extract we can
track
its concentration changes with time and
then we can fit a sigmoidal curve
to the uptake of that compound
and so from that curve fit we can
extract parameters of interest such as
the amplitude how much was
assimilated the t50 or the
the inflection point of assimilation
the width or um which relates to how
fast or slow the compound is used
and then what i did is i took that width
and i expanded it to show a 90
usage window so we can really look at
compounds
at their 10 percent used and 90 used
uh points and so i'm showing these these
fits because in the future
uh plots i'm going to just show the t50
and the 90
usage window so we can look at when the
substrates are used
along the growth curve
so here is this figure this is for the
growth curve of
para berkold area solitude and soil
extract
so again we have time on the x-axis
biomass on the y
the black line is showing biomass
growth accumulation and you can see that
we see distinct clusters of
substrate use so i missed quite a few
early
on which i called type 1 here and i've
just counted them
over here but each of these is a t50 so
a midpoint of usage
and the bars on the x-axis show the
the usage window so the main takeaways
from this
experiment was that our quantified
compounds explained
about three quarters of carbon and
nitrogen removal from the media
so while we didn't we only quantified a
certain amount it explained a large
portion of what was actually being
metabolized
and we saw distinct clusters of
substrate
depletion at least three maybe more
and this distinct clustering in my mind
implies multi-oxic growth so we have
different groups of simultaneous
substrate usage
and the one other thing i want to point
out which maybe if you're good at
squinting you can see in this figure but
i'll show a regression
is we saw no clear trend with nominal
oxidation state
and substrate preference so if i plot
t50 on the
y-axis versus nominal oxidation state on
the x
we see no clear trend and so the colored
points are quantified substrates and
i've also overlained
untargeted compounds so compounds we
can't quantify but i can
assign them or calculate a nominal
oxidation state
um so we saw no support for that
hypothesis
in this in this study
so from there we
had to make a decision to make defined
media
so we looked at what substrates we could
quantify
and we really at that point wanted to
remove concentration
as a confounding variable so we chose 25
micromolar as a reasonable concentration
to make a defined media with and we move
forward
with creating that media with 34 total
carbon sources
three sugars 21 amino acids and 10
organic acids
again they're all at 25 micromolar we
supplemented with ammonium because that
was present in soil extract as well as
phosphate
and then we also supplemented with
wolf's trace mineral solution in vitamin
mix
we bumped the ph up a little here but
it's still at an acidic ph of ph4 and we
use this for our further
experimentation
so for this work we we really wanted to
ask questions again about substrate
preferences such as use efficiency and
carbon use efficiency but
across multiple uh different isolates so
not just
uh the pero burkhold area solitude
so we chose three species with different
growth rates
and i've just put the name of their
closest
relative based on amplicon sequence
sequencing and so we have two gram
negatives
uh a raustonia and then the parabola
area i mentioned earlier and then a
fungus
uh penicillin spinulosum and this
represents a growth rate gradient
so the fungus is much slower growing
than the two gram-negative bacteria
we then chose five substrates in
particular to add as
labeled as isotope labeled substrates so
we could track
the carbon and nitrogen from those
substrates specifically
and here we had two amino acids valine
and glycine
a sugar glucose and then two organic
acids
acetate and formate
and then from a practical perspective
the way this experiment was conducted
is uh we grew up these isolates into log
phase and then used those to inoculate
a culture flask containing the
media with all 34 substrates but just
one isotope labeled substrate for each
treatment then we could take gas
measurements to monitor
co2 production and label co2 production
collect biomass with time
monitor substrate uptake and
for each of these experiments we did at
least four time points
sample
so there's a lot of data here but i'm
just going to point out a couple
quick takeaways to orient you i'm
showing the microbes on the bottom
with decreasing growth rate for each of
these figures biomass is on the y-axis
and time is on
the x-axis you'll notice that the x-axis
gets larger as you move to the right
that's because they're growing slower so
the growth curve
takes more time to capture you'll also
notice that the y-axis increases as well
as you move to the right so
with decreasing growth rate there was
more biomass production
and i just want to point out that all of
these microbes assimilated all of the
substrates that we put in the media
which perhaps isn't surprising but all
sugars amino acids
and organic acids that we put were
assimilated
and we can monitor that with time again
looking at the t50 so the inflection
point of uptake in the usage window
and so again it's hard to to squint and
and bring out a pattern with oxidation
state so we can do a regression
so here i'm looking at the inflection
point the t50
of each substrate as a function of
the oxidation state of of that of the
carbon in that substrate
and what what uh comes out of that is
that we see
uh indications of a trend supporting our
our hypothesis for the two bacterial
species
so we see that the oxidized the more
oxidized compounds are used earlier on
during growth and we see less of a trend
for
the fungal species
and so i'm going i'm in the process
right now going back through and making
sure that i'm confident
in all of these fits because we've done
a lot of sigmoidal fitting here
uh but this seems to be the uh the story
that's coming out here is that we see a
trend with the bacterial isolates but
not with the fungal isolate
so then we can look at the respiration
data
so again we have three figures and i'm
showing enrich 13c
co2 on the y and time on the x
each of the five labeled substrates i
mentioned earlier are
have a different pastel color here
and again the main takeaway here
is that i can capture kinetics of
respiration
of these compounds and then to calculate
substrate use efficiency
i can take the the final value the
cumulative respire 13 cco2
and use that in my formula so if i know
how much
of that isotope is in the biomass and i
know how much was cumulatively respired
i can calculate sue so what i did is at
the
at the end of these curves i can take
this final value along with a
measurement of the biomass
to measure suv
so here are those final plots
again we have nominal oxidation state of
carbon on the x
and substrate use efficiency on the y um
the first thing i want to point out here
is that decreasing growth rate did
result in higher carbon use efficiency
so in this more realistic soil solution
environment
media that we've chosen we see that the
the fungus
grows much more efficiently than the two
bacterial species
and we see a trend with growth rate
the other thing i want to point out is
that
there are not clear trends with nominal
oxidation state of carbon
so if we look just at the
peri-berkelederia species
we can see trends similar to what we see
in the literature where the more
oxidized formate
is used much less efficiently but that's
less clear
for the raustonia or the penicillin
species
for all cases formate was used much less
efficiently
than any of the other substrates and we
see some indication
by inference you can see that there are
other substrates in the media that must
be used less efficiently than these
three
for ralstonia because the average is
much lower
um the same with a parabola
as well um but it's less clear with the
penicillin where it looks like
the average matches much more closely
with with some of the
substrates we chose to monitor
okay so i'm going to move on now to
the final portion which is focused on
adsorption
and so the questions we wanted to ask
here is what what functional groups are
predominantly involved in necromas
absorption
do these differ with phylogeny and then
what is the stability of
that mineral associated organic matter
after it is formed
and so to do this work we use an
instrument that's the workhorse of
our lab the atr ftir
and this instrument allows us to
collect interfacial observations of
of or collect ftir data at the interface
of the mineral and solution
so we can play we can place a mineral
film
on this diamond stabilize it and then
flow a solution over it
monitor sorption in real time
so here's an example this is just one of
the many
experiments i've run showing absorption
of bacterial necromass
and so you know with time in red you see
sorption so what starts off as
you know no vibrations quickly we see
peaks show up
and we can assign those peaks to
different functional groups
uh and then i haven't shown it here but
with time we can also watch desorption
as the spectra drop back down
uh if we change the environment um or
change the solution flowing through
the instrument
so for the sake of the talk today and
for time i'm going to be very simplistic
with this and just point out
two portions of microbial necromas that
we can focus on
because they look quite different and
that is protein
so protein and dna and here i've shown
two spectra from
an old lab mate of mine mike schmidt
and so for the protein spectra we can
see that it's dominated by
amide 1 and mi2 bands which we also see
in our necromas that's sorbing and then
dna which
is also has vibrations in this region
but has much higher relative vibrations
that we can assign to po or
cc backbone vibrations in the dna
molecule
and i'm just going to get you to focus
on those two
in-members for for the rest of the talk
so for these experiments i took
necromass from these
different microbes and i
uh adsorbed them to a gertite thin film
so first we stabilized the film with
background kcl
and electrolyte that's common in soil
solution
and then we absorb the necromass by
flowing that
repeatedly over the mineral and so that
necromass has been
sonicated the cell has been broken open
and it's sterile so we we conduct
sorption and then we change the solution
to induce desorption first we just
remove the necromass just have a
background electrolyte
then we increase the ionic strength ten
fold
and then we add an organic ligand
oxalate
and we chose that because it is commonly
been so shown to
induce desorption um and so we wanted to
see if we could use that to kick off
some
some of this sort of micro mass
so again here i've shown three figures
for the three
isolates i've chosen to work with for
now
these red spectra are just the
necromance themselves
and i don't want to get too caught up on
individual peaks but the main thing i
want to point out is that the microbial
necro or the
bacterial necromancer is much more
similar it's dominated by
a protein signature so the mi1 and mi2
peaks
and that the fungal necromass has a much
decreased relative protein signature
and looks a lot more like dna so it has
a higher
relative coc cc and po vibrations
and so those are over in this lower
region right versus the amide one and
mi2 which are clear
in these two bacterial isolates
so then we can look at at equilibrium
adsorption on the gertite10 film and the
main takeaways here that i
i want uh to get at is that we see
selective preservation so the the
spectra are different right we don't see
all uh portions of necromass equally
absorbed on this grotite mineral
we see increased relative coc
cc and po vibrations which are all dna
associated or can be
upon sorption
so then ongoing work that i'm involved
in with right now
is looking at the kinetics absorption
and the stability
and so we can break this spectra up into
regions of interest
and for the sake of this talk i'm going
to talk i'm going to mention
amide 1 mi2 which are both related to
protein
and then this region that's more
associated with dna down here
and we can monitor those by integrating
those regions so we can monitor those
with time during absorption
when we change to just our background
electrolyte when we increase the ionic
strength
and then when we add an organic ligand
and so we can see
absorption and then desorption using
this approach
and so again if we look at our three
isolates um the main thing i want to
point out here is that we see sorption
for all of them
uh and then we see desorption with our
phases
and we see distinct kinetic patterns for
both absorption and desorption
and so the work that i'm currently doing
to finish up this chapter
is modeling the kinetics of these
absorption and desorption events and
comparing them between
the three isolates
and let's see yeah so
i think overall to wrap up i hope i've
shown
or convince you that exo metabolomic
methods are
a really important way to better
understand microbial physiology
at realistic substrate concentrations so
because of these low detection limits
we can grow and monitor these microbes
at very low substrate concentrations
we saw evidence that faster growing
microbes tend to metabolize carbon less
efficiently
so they had a lower carbon use
efficiency we saw some indications that
more oxidized compounds were used
earlier during growth at least for the
bacteria
the two bacteria we investigated so
higher nominal
oxidation state of carbon resulted in
lower
t50 or earlier uptake we saw no clear
trend
between nominal oxidation state of
carbon and substrate use efficiency
uh and then lastly we're i have some
preliminary data showing that
preferential adsorption of dna
associated functional groups
from necromas from all isolates and i'm
currently working to
to compare the kinetics of those
processes
and then of course there are always
caveats um
the the uptake relationship that i did
see was only clear at equimolar
substrate levels right if you think back
to the first chapter we didn't see it in
the soil extract
so if we were to incorporate that into
any modeling efforts
substrate concentration would need to be
a factor there
i also want to caveat again i'm only
talking about aerobic respiration
here things may be very different in
other metabolic
environments and then lastly i've done
this work
using individual isolates to ask
questions about basic
microbial metabolism but no microbe is
an island
and so things may be different once
you're operating in a community
so just want to throw those caveats out
there um
none of this work would be possible
without lots of help from those
in my lab including mike ariel and
beiru's
the buckley lab who have graciously let
me use their lab space and put up with
me
for all these years i'd like to
especially thank dr
roland wilhelm for his mentorship and dr
lumia
aristilde and dr annelise klein for
their help with uh
exo metabolomic measurements and so with
that i'd like to thank everyone for
their attention and open the floor for
any question
shoes dominic hi hi taylor thank you
that was a
wonderful presentation and as a model i
really appreciated you
saying early on that you wanted to
produce stuff that's useful to modelers
and i think you've definitely done that
it's
it's fascinating to me to think about
how i can put some of this
into models i'm wondering a little bit
about your
the carbon use efficiency so you didn't
find strong evidence of oxygen
oxidation state being a good predictor
and from
from the modeling community people
typically expect it to be driven far
more by the c
to n ratio because growth has a
stoichiometric demand for
carbon use efficiency has to back match
the stoichiometry of growth
did you think about trying to correlate
your data with the cn ratio of the
substrates and whether that's a better
fit
and i said for example with formate it's
also got a extremely high an infinite c
to end ratio so we would expect on that
basis
to see the low cue that you found i
wonder if c
c to n could be mapped against that
whether you did that
yeah thank you so much for that question
um so just to reiterate the question was
if i'd looked at c to n ratio as a
possible
predictor and uh yeah i mean i think
coming from the
like larger scale work like my master's
work was found that aur to n which is
just a different version of c to n ratio
was very useful as a predictor at that
scale
uh but at these scales i saw no
relationship with that either
and then the other issue with some of
these compounds like you mentioned have
no nitrogen at all
so how do you you know i don't i i took
subsets of the amino acids and tried to
use that as a predictor with no
with no use or with no uh clear
regression either
thanks for that question i hope yeah
thank you yeah
hi this is totally outside my area so
this may be a
not a helpful question at all but
it looked like with some of your
comparisons you were using the
inflection point
which of course is harder to quantify
than
if you moved a little further along in
the time
course
so instead of using a 50th percentile
use some higher percentile i'm just
curious about i guess it's sort of a
methodology question of
of why you choose that for the for the
further fitting
hmm let's see let's think through this
um
trying to find the slide and again this
is outside my area so this you know no
no that's a good question
i i guess my thinking like just off the
bat thinking about that would be that
um because of the way the sigmoid is fit
if i choose let's say 75 or 25 um
oh i see what you're saying
i guess to me i was just thinking about
centering it right to think about the
midpoint of
use and then you know depending on the
shape of that sigmoid you'll have a
wider
or smaller uptake window um
but you're saying like use like the 25th
percent
yeah it's just a question it seems like
the highest uncertainty is at that
50th percentile so you would have more
seems like you'd have more precision if
you used
say a higher percentile
okay i can certainly try that that's the
easy
just you know calculation and re-plot
so i'll think about that thank you
i was wondering um tyler thank you very
much for
for this wonderful presentation looks uh
amazing what all the work you did
um i i wanted to go back to the nos
question
and and how well the mosque um
uh your compounds um approximate the
the uh the average of uh that you found
in your concoction
uh and for for the for the fungus you
didn't find
uh it sort of aligned with with the
average so um
not that it characterizes necessarily
what's in that concoction but
what are you missing in the bacteria um
that uh um
that is not in in your
in your model substances here yeah
exactly um
so what what are your what other
compound classes that you think could
balance the budget here to get you to
the average
yeah so that's a really good question um
thank you uh so the the good thing here
is this is defined media so i know
exactly what
is available there's only 34 options um
so so in the case of the two bacteria it
could be that they're using
um several of those amino acids or
probably organic acids
less efficiently um right and that
that would be it just you know from a
practical perspective i could only probe
five um right but if we probe them all
then we could
ensure right and i would expect a lot of
the others
to be below this curve right um
uh so i guess short answer is i would
guess organic acids
um but i can't say for sure without
probing that
um and then the fungus like you
mentioned is more interesting
because it almost insinuates that most
of the substrates
might be used with the same use
efficiency right and maybe this format
is just an outlier
and so i'm trying to think through it
kind of really gets at a core
question is are these substrates being
used at vastly different use
efficiencies
or being used at the same time
divergently in metabolism
um or are they all being used with
similar use efficiencies
and and when so it seems that that your
organisms
are doing very different things
but the the compounds are
are have a less of an effect well maybe
there's a little bit of a slant in all
of your data but but maybe less than you
expected
so so does that mean that that organism
is more important or organism class more
important than compounds
for for this whole growth question
well yeah i think clearly the metabolism
of the organism
is the most important thing right that's
going to define how these these
substrates are used
and what i guess i was hopeful to find
is if we could
kind of forget about that right and find
a broader framework
because that would be great for modeling
right you wouldn't have to measure
the specific metabolism of each of these
organisms to predict right you could you
could have just a large framework
um and so i don't know if i i don't
think i have compelling evidence that we
can use this one parameter right and
solve the problem
and predict uptake so yeah
but it's it's always one organism right
i mean as you said in your caveat
uh this is there's
you're not looking at a community of
organs
so that's a key point in a community
right we may see a shift where
um let's say i'm this middle organism
pear berkold area so
too gay maybe i can't get at the glycine
as fast as
someone else in the community so how
efficiently i use that
may be less of a factor right because
there's there's competition there
yeah or i might have decided to uh
focus on one compound because that's my
niche right there's there's lots of ways
we could think about
how that might play out great thank you
wonderful thank you
oh uh we have another question yeah
um oh yeah i turn on my video
so thank you taylor that was a very very
interesting talk and good seeing you
i have a question concerning also the
carbon use efficiency
and how it was measured experimentally
because i might not have caught
everything you were talking about
you are measuring the optical density in
your solution
and you take that as a proxy for the
growing microorganisms
is that correct
so let's see if i can go back
so very good question i know i went
quickly through this
so i measured optical density uh which
correlates with biomass
and with protein but i i actually
physically measured biomass with this
if you can see my arrow with this
filtration step
so the assumption here is that
everything greater than 0.2 microns
is my cell we're going to say that's
biomass
and so i could physically weigh that
mass that
as well as measure the the amount of
carbon by difference so i could take a
solution over to the shimadzu
unfiltered and then a solution filtered
and by difference
no the carbon in the biomass
so okay so you used
the filtration of larger than the size
of your bacteria or
fungal to say that's my living biomass
to separate it from from that material
yeah so that's a good point is that it's
not
it's not perfect there are maybe some
dead cells in there right but that the
assumption is
once the cell breaks open that a good
portion of that should go through
the filter it's very interesting because
i
i know it's difficult to measure so it's
relatively easy to model it but um to
get hard data on it
we are having difficulties so i'll
probably come back
to you and ask more questions
yeah i know it's very hard to measure in
an actual soil
and i almost laughed when this one
organism ended up being
0.4 which i think is the default
modeling number
thank you for your question um thanks
for answering
okay uh are you down
yeah i might allow another question
because i didn't see other hands up
please oh yes yes sure
um so i just yeah i was wondering about
um how we would translate this maybe you
haven't thought about it so maybe it's
an unfair question how do we translate
this to what happens in a soil
because we often find that cut use
efficiency is very much higher in an
aqueous broth because you don't have to
forage or compete with other organisms
or
compete with uptake against minerals and
all that sort of thing and i think we
typically see
i don't think you ever see cues in the
sort of 75 80 percent
in a soil environment whereas you do see
them during the growth phase in an
aqueous
slurry um which is a much easier
environment for organism to live in
so i'm wondering how how would i how
would it be possible to take what you've
done here and
what lessons could we actually translate
into the soil environment and which ones
are very specific to
an aqueous solution
yeah i totally agree with you that in a
real soil things will train
change dramatically and i think my my
most
my basic goal was to provide some
parameters because i see these estimates
starting to be or these types of numbers
like uptake kinetic values being put in
the models
and there's very little data to
parameterize that so if nothing else i
i hope to provide like bounds on what
uptick rates might be
in solution um but you're right the
the carbon use efficiency of one of
these isolates might change drastically
if i put a mineral
in the flask right but the problem is
it's just very hard for me
at least with the methods i had
available to to measure cue
in that situation right so um
yeah now i create a really difficult
yeah problem to tackle it's
so much easier to work in these
simplified things environments i'm just
wondering
like as a model and you know how much
can you take from these environments and
to assume that things look anything like
that
in a soil and maybe that's a stretch
yeah i have to i mean we are totally
over time but i just want to say that
taylor you did have some experience
trying to do that experiment that
dominic was talking about right
basically putting the mineral in the in
the in the flask
and what happened there
yeah so that's a fun uh i could give a
whole nother talk on failed phd
experiments but uh i started off at one
point trying to do
to add minerals into the mix right and
the problem is everything died instantly
and so i spent a couple months on um
it was it was fun actually on side
projects trying to understand
if the microbes were dying because
mycertite was sorbing all the phosphate
and so then we have a nutrient
limitation issue or if it was directly
killing the microbes
and there's a whole interesting side
literature on the needle morphology of
gertite and how it may pierce
bacterial cells if you're looking for
like a good sunday afternoon read i
encourage that but um
yeah it it's hard i guess this is where
i'll end
with that yeah
yeah all right so yeah so it's 120
oh okay good so i just have a question
i don't see any more hands so
i think we can uh photoshop for today
right
okay and if anyone has other questions
you can email me at any time
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu